trimming this book as
he then gives us the purpose
the leading the center thrust of the
purpose of this book. Why was this book
sent down?
Well, one of the points of this book is
Forchech.
[Silence]
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells
us that he sent this book down in order
to warn of a very terrible and violent
punishment. ment
that he possesses subhanahu wa ta'ala
a violent punishment for those who
ignore those who turn away those who
fight against this book those who reject
this book a very violent punishment
he says and in order to give glad
tidings and good news and great hope
to those believers who work righteous
deeds
and to inform them that he as well
possesses for them a very good
and perfect reward. This is in reference
to paradise.
So the reward is good in itself. What is
the fear we as human beings have?
Something is good. We're afraid for it
to end, right?
all of us. And that's one of the ironies
of this dunya
is that you can't really enjoy anything
without death
following you around. Right? That's
why the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
referred to death as
And so this is why the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam referred to death
as the destroyer of pleasures. It ruins
anything pleasureful. Anything anything
of this anything that ends with death it
ruins it because even if you're not
dying now you're going to die
eventually. So no matter how vivid any
enjoyment is, what ruins it ultimately?
The end. It has to end sometime.
But paradise, it is not plagued by such
endings.
It is eternal.
As the hellfire is eternal.
But Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
has left indicators throughout the
Quran. Everywhere in the Quran,
everywhere in the Quran,
there is an essence
of his statement
in
the prophet sallall.aii Wasam said that
when Allah concluded the creation of the
heavens and the earth
and rose above his throne, he wrote in a
book which he has with him to this day,
"My mercy has exceeded my anger.
My mercy has superseded my anger." And
you'll find this pattern everywhere in
the Quran. Anytime
the mercy of Allah and the punishment of
Allah are mentioned somewhere, there's
an indicator in there somewhere.
Sometimes it's very subtle, very
nuanced, but there is always an
indicator in there of
you will find that his insistence on
mercy whenever it's mentioned in the
Quran alongside his anger and
punishment,
you'll find nuanced in there
something subtle, sometimes very subtle
that carry carries the spirit of
my mercy has superseded my anger. My
mercy has exceeded my anger. And here we
have the same thing he mentions.
And this verse is no different. He says
that to warn of a very violent
punishment that he possesses, but to
also give glad tidings of paradise that
continues forever. And he didn't say
that the punishment continues forever.
In order to articulate that point,
[Arabic recitation]